the origins of mysticism in Andalusia in
general is often traced to the
fascinating 9th to 10th Century Mystic
philosopher IBN masara he was born in
the city of Cordoba around the year 883
where he started teaching and became
famous as an ascetic and mystical guide
and it is said that IBN Masada and his
followers would Retreat to the mountains
surrounding Cordoba where they spent
most of their time in religious and
spiritual practice at the center of
ibimasada's thought is the concept of
etibar meaning contemplation we can
Ascend to a Divine experience through
the practice of contemplation
this can be done through ascending
levels of contemplation in a very
neoplatonic way where one contemplates
and meditates on nature itself the
beauty of the world around us
the world is after all often described
as the cosmic Quran as a sacred
scripture that can be read by those with
eyes to see properly